is that what they call this you know
Dean's just hate that Cody is the last
vote congratulations Josh your boat
surprised a lot of people what did it
come down to for you I mean I don't like
Ian's room so it's just one of those
deals where Paul was like behind some
curtain while josh is actually heads up
in my face so I actually respect that
more than somebody that's supposedly a
public master behind a curve it just
shows that he's he's exactly who I
thought he was he flipped the house he
flipped the vote and it was very
satisfying to watch what's the plan
tonight though get drunk make out with
her behind I don't know some stage
somewhere without cameras around yeah
yeah you guys as soon as you could you
guys we saw you kissing on TV tonight
[Laughter]
Julie has said when I interview a few
weeks ago and tonight you guys are the
couple that's gonna make it out of this
season when you saw Cody tonight what
went through your head and he smelled
good so like once the cameras were off I
was just like in his neck and like
didn't leave there well you were in his
neck while the cameras were still on
when you got to see her tonight after
weeks apart what was the first thing
that went through your head no no it's
not appropriate for television I am just
extremely happy to be with her I haven't
been around somebody I've trusted for
who knows how long so I'm just happy to
be around somebody you can trust
is this your forever girl
she's over there I gotta be quiet I
think after tonight you're gonna see us
permanently attached to each other well
he move out here while you move to Texas
do we have any of those ideas and play
yet have a game plan you guys will have
to wait and see
and we know step one of the game plan
actually you can't oh I'll take it but
she probably knows the plan better idea
I'll go with whatever Jess wants to do
and the winner is
congratulations Cody you want America's
favorite did that surprise you yeah I
don't understand that at all you know
who's responsible for that right I am
assuming Jessica she campaigned like
hell for me oh yeah when people were
voting for her she said stop voting for
me and toss it behind my man gosh she's
awesome
like they she presses me every day she's
incredible I couldn't be more satisfied
so thank you everybody who voted for
Cody for America's favorite player
[Music]